ho vissuto i miei primi diciassette anni
in modo meraviglioso partite a calcio
all'oratorio grandissimo divertimento
con gli amici con la famiglia è tanto
studio quello veramente veramente no ma
tanta voglia di lavorare a quell'età
ero già artigiano professionista con mio
padre e quelle poche risorse in più che
avevo mi hanno permesso di acquistare
questa moto nel 89 un sogno veramente
per pochi miei coetanei in quel momento
ricordo benissimo di avere quella
convinzione di tenere completamente la
vita nelle mie mani poter decidere in
ogni momento cosa farà cadere nella mia
vita ma soprattutto cose non fare
accadere nella mia vita e il 28 agosto
del 1990 quella quella convinzione con
la credenza sia completamente sgretolata
attraverso un incidente un incidente
motociclistico contro contro una vettura
che ha fatto completamente perdere la
mia gamba e cambiare di conseguenza la
mia vita mi sono svegliato il giorno
dopo con le gambe e meno e tantissimi
sogni sogni cambiati in quel momento in
quel letto di ospedale in quei cinque
mesi di vigenza dopo l'incidente una
domanda era ma è veramente finita è la
fine di una vita meravigliosa o
addirittura una nuova opportunità di
vita per renderla ancora più
straordinaria e mi son trovato i primi
obiettivi primi importanti obiettivi
questa è una foto che ritrae quel
momento a distanza di circa 10 mesi dove
una manifestazione di 54 km
la preparazione la sua partecipazione
solamente dieci mesi mi ha fatto
veramente capire che il successo della
mia vita dal punto di vista familiare
sportivo e lavorativo non sarebbe stato
determinato necessariamente dal numero
delle mie gambe ma da tutto ciò che
avevo per tutto ciò che avevo nella
nella testa e da lì sono arrivati i
primi traguardi una una perdita di una
gamba 17 anni ma che non mi ha mai fatto
perdere la voglia di vivere la voglia di
fare di fare sport e in ogni momento che
ho vissuto c'era proprio la voglia di
ritornare ritornare a correre ma
soprattutto di superare veramente al
cento per cento una necessità che avevo
io al cento per cento la mia disabilità
ho portato la protesi x 10 x 10 mesi i
miei tredici anni mi hanno sempre
garantito che sarei ritornato alla
persona di prima ma una disabilità come
la mia puoi rendere comunque
meravigliose la vita ma non sarai mai la
persona di prima e man mano passavano i
mesi man mano passavano gli anni mi
rendevo conto che la mia vita non era
più quella di prima e dovevo
concentrarmi su ciò che mi era rimasto
anziché su ciò che avevo perso ho
rinunciato la protesi c'è stata una una
gru un grosso percorso lungo percorso di
accettazione perché comunque avere
sempre gli occhi addosso
non è facile ma soprattutto
l'accettazione di rinunciare per sempre
alla possibilità di ritornare a correre
come fa immagino ognuno ognuno di voi
finché la potenza dei nostri sogni la
posizione un grandissimo sognatore la
potenza dei nostri sogni dei nostri
pensieri di come comunichiamo poi noi
con lo stesso mi ha permesso veramente
in questi 26 anni di raggiungere
obiettivi straordinari nel lavoro una
barriera mentale che mia viene
installato siccome mi mancava una gamba
non avrei più trovato la fidanzata o una
moglie e una moglie bellissima ciò due
figlie straordinarie e da lì poi sono
arrivati degli obiettivi importanti
sportivi dove impara triathlon nuoto
bici e corsa mi ha regalato poi la
soddisfazione di ritornare a correre con
le stampelle e vincerà anche una
medaglia
d'argento ai campionati europei è
arrivata all avventura nel ciclismo e le
avventure strade sulla strada sulla
strada carrozzabile più alta del mondo è
arrivata la parigi brest tutte tutte
manifestazioni tutte gare tutte
occasioni tutti vinti nella mia vita che
mi hanno fatto capire che era giunto
veramente il momento di intraprendere
questo percorso di crescita personale e
soprattutto portarlo alle altre alle
altre persone è iniziato il percorso di
crescita personale che mi ha poi fatto
diventare un mental coach da due anni
professionista e in questo percorso
assieme ad altri amici 45 amici abbiamo
creato progetto 22 per vari motivi
pilastro fondamentale le 22 risorse e
condividendo le nostre storie ci siamo
resi conto che un evento dall età dai 14
ai 20 anni aveva completamente cambiato
la vita che se non interpretato in modo
potenziante in modo costruttivo
veramente l'avrebbe potuta distruggere
ma ci siamo trovati in una falsità dai
40 55 anni ad avere delle vite
meravigliose perciò un progetto dedicato
ai ragazzi che con l'elemento fondale in
fondamentale il pilastro più più grande
quello delle risorse cosa ci ha permesso
veramente di uscire pienamente da questo
da questo evento sono state appunto le
nostre risorse
abbiamo voluto sommare una cosa è creare
un sogno utopistico per noi quello del
giro d'italia formativo eventi formativi
nelle scuole nel mattino e nel
pomeriggio coprire la distanza in sella
alle nostre bici da un istituto
all'altro cioè tota pendant da dal 70 80
e 100 km ogni giorno io uso sempre il il
plurale perché comunque è un progetto
nato da da tutti noi anche se poi al
pomeriggio in bici sotto il sole l'acqua
nebbia grandine sono sempre io da solo
ogni invito sempre anche gli studenti ma
me ne vado anche un po a cercare infatti
adesso però ho capito che devo
accorciare un pochino le città anziché
farle 110 km soprattutto non fare tappe
come napoli roma di quasi 200 quali me
la sono proprio andate a cercare e è un
sogno utopistico ma in cui veramente
credevamo tanto abbiamo proposto a
tantissime persone non abbiamo avuto
tantissimi consensi ma il desiderio e la
voglia di partire con la dizione 0 e poi
creare le altre ci ha permesso in
febbraio di concludere la terza edizione
e raggiungere e superare direttamente
nelle scuole oltre 12.000 ragazzi in
interventi come questi queste sono le
nostre 22 risorse e è un progetto che
porteremo avanti 22 risorse fondamentali
per noi son quelli che abbiamo scelto
noi ma ce ne sono tantissime le altre è
come scoprire le nostre risorse
molte volte siamo concentrati sulle
sulle cose durante la giornata che
potevano andare meglio l'interrogazione
il voto il contratto e tante altre cose
quando invece se ci concentriamo sulle
cose meravigliose che durante la
giornata accadono scopriamo che noi in
quei momenti abbiamo veramente messo in
campo le nostre le nostre risorse e ci
impedì cosa ci impedisce molte volte
anche ragazzi di riscoprirle il fatto di
essere focalizzati sui nostri miti cioè
vedere trasmissioni dove ci sono
l'eccellenza veramente del canto della
recita vedere il film quando noi in quel
momento vediamo solo l'apice dell'hiv ci
vediamo solo la punta di tutto lavoro
che c'è stato dietro e dobbiamo essere
consapevoli che noi come loro abbiamo il
nostro interno le risorse e abbiamo
anche loro talenti il talento che va
appunto ogni giorno nutrito con le
nostre risorse
come fare a scoprirle una
una tecnica molto molto pratica andare a
vedere quello che già oggi noi facciamo
di straordinaria nostra vita che può
essere come dice sempre un mio amico
anche la casalinga che fa il risotto che
mangiamo alla domenica nostra madre io
non sono capace di farlo perciò capire
veramente le risorse che metterà in
campo capire perché siamo ben voluti
dalla no dai nostri amici in ambito
lavorativo in ambito sportivo in quel
momento noi mettiamo in campo e
utilizziamo le risorse sappiamo di avere
dentro di noi e in quel momento poterle
metterla in tutte le aste le altre
nostre abilità e perché con scoprirle
perché ci permettono di scoprire poi il
nostro percorso unico di di vita perché
questo sassofono 1 perché lo suonato per
per otto anni ma ho voluto simboleggiare
oggi la situazione un po che c'è in
italia almeno rimaniamo il nostro paese
dei ragazzi rimasti un po demotivati
forse anche noi adulti abbiamo una
responsabilità questi incontri servono
appunto per stimolarli nella fiducia in
se stessi nella motivazione e nel
ritrovare la propria la propria
autostima e quel cavalletto proprio di
fianco al sassofono per simboleggiare
che la situazione la soluzione non è
lontanissima e può essere veramente lì a
fianco
perciò mi viene di rivolgermi ai
dirigenti agli insegnanti
pensate se gli incontri formativi che
facciamo noi come progetto 22 fossero
una cosa diffusissima in tutta italia sa
quante opportunità e quanti strumenti
daremmo in più di quello che già date
agli ai nostri giovani
poi mi rivolgo a voi genitori a genitori
sono genitori anch'io se stiamo già
veramente facendo tutto del nostro
meglio per per il bene dei nostri
ragazzi
o a volte veniamo un po a volte un po
abbiamo un po colpiti dal nostro egoismo
di raggiungere i nostri obiettivi
anziché dei quelli dei nostri ragazzi e
poi mi rivolgo proprio a voi ragazzi
perché gli è stata donata la vita vi è
stata avete l'opportunità veramente
unita di poter creare
della vostra vita quello che volete i
vostri sogni i vostri pensieri per il
momento sono nella vostra testa ma
mettendo in campo le risorse e
continuando a sognare coltivare i vostri
talenti nella vostra vita si
realizzeranno sicuramente tutti i vostri
sogni e questo un po quello che con
progetto 22
desideriamo fare grazie